[Musik]
viel spaß
die hin und weg wünscht dr oetker
[Musik]
ich will zu dir nach hause
ich habe angst dass ich alles verlieren
werde
[Musik]
ich habe mir immer gesagt die frau die
ich meiner mutter vorstelle die werde
ich heiraten darf ich sagen dass du mich
gefragt hat ob ich zu dir nach hause
kommen
okay das ist so peinlich für dich ja ein
bisschen ins team
[Musik]
morden norditalien sie als die haie vor
simona bäumer und ihre familie
[Musik]
die heirat des spanischen schweizer
tisch im kinsky lernte italienisch
es ist gut gegangen besten selber auch
draußen gut danke
[Musik]
mir hat sie denkt dass sie mit ihrer
familie einmal im ausland bleibe seit
simona aber dann hätte sie verliert und
mit dem kran sind auto ihres laibach one
maschine schoss spanien hat bei ferrari
sein traumjob kunde im home office muss
ich schauen ferrari-ingenieure
familienautos normalerweise arbeite ich
im kleinen nebenzimmer
aber wenn die kinder zu laut sind ziehe
ich mich hierhin zurück
da kann ich zwei türen hinter mir
schließen es ist ruhiger mit dem team
motoren für formel 1 bolide richtig
gewöhnt hochpräzise schafe im umgang mit
der zeit nimmt auch stunden und 20
minuten zu rechnen dass ich wirklich
direkt punkte verschiebe teilemanagement
ich ich bin selten zu spät
ich kenne sehr viele schweizer die auch
zu spät kommen probiere ist die tatsache
dass - navis war da wenn wir sport grund
aber dass sie einfacher das ist so tief
kann man vor schlimmer für andere kino
sind herrn simona und horloff nbc klebt
er ist paris zieht unter die hayek sie
sich ob das mit dem musiker wie das
funktioniert aber nachhaltig so frank
für mich nur der familie planen
der familie haar das 1 bei die wähler
aber es ist simonazzi wurde für heimat
der job und karriere aufgehellt
[Musik]
ergotherapeutin mega einbruch sie selbst
ein ganz aktuelles leben dieter k
du bist wenn du an fast alles zurück was
auch das ungleichgewicht gibt es momente
der bezirk oder auch ein schwieriger so
dass das ungleichgewicht mit so er das
land sachsen und davon und das nichts
mit wenn ihm die kette der von beruf
moment fliegt diskussion ist oder
unstimmigkeit konnte das wieder für das
so innerlich so die frustrationen die
bdp und der aus zurück und ist oder
warum so spannend denn er nachts signal
sowie der eigentlich hätte das so im
regen
ich hab gesagt dass du ein
muttersöhnchen
wer struckmeier verzichtet zugunsten
andere das richtige gleichgewicht finde
ich für jede beziehung essentiell in
binationalen sind so entscheid besonders
wenn simone etwas will dann kämpft sie
dafür
sie hat eine starke persönlichkeit das
ist gut für ferrari zu arbeiten das ist
ein traum für mich eine chance die ich
einfach ergreifen musste
[Musik]
was nun wieder passiert ist
romina ich kann eben betrunken im taxi
vom wiener schlechter erfahrungen mit
amerikaner verzichten und den eigentlich
so kommt doch nicht auf blöde gedanken
ja aber man hat dann ja noch da
verbracht
richtig angefühlt westend blöd aber das
ist so wie der bayerische blick
ich bleibe
und hawkeye magnus ist dazu euro
[Musik]
neues im blauen land und kalifornien
sind sieben jahresbahn
nimm das
neu ist die einzige aus ihrer familie
das klamme land bekommen hat
[Musik]
ihre schwester fabienne nämlich gute
flugstunde weiter westlich fifa schlag
vorbei ich hätte nie gedacht dass es so
schöne muschel finden würde
[Musik]
ende
ferry ich auch aber ich glaube ich noch
sonstige hannawald nordamerika weiß nie
was für sie ich habe das nur dass wir
die beiden amerika zirkus ist einfach so
passiert aber wenigstens immer nur das
kabinett wehr trotz liebe und glück neue
form ist ihre familie und die vertraute
umgebung
corona und der start da und mach' es nun
schwerer musiker und freunde treffe dort
nehme und weckte reisebeschränkungen
besuch in san francisco müssen ab 60
ihre familie schon im xi
es war das erste mal dass neue lehrer
familie in der schweiz so lange nicht
sehen konnte das hat ihr sehr zugesetzt
ich sagte ihr wenn deine schule
einwilligt von der schweiz aus zu
arbeiten dann buch ein ticket und flieg
heim
und genau das hat neue gemacht
[Musik]
noch enger freunde hat er sich hunger
oder da bin in der schweiz überhaupt
nicht
das ist politisch 17 uhr und schließen
um ihre mutter überrasche hat sie früher
nie weiß wo der neuen ihres ahnungslose
mammut zum kaffee
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
[Musik]
das gab bei gerechtere innerhalb vom
halbjahr um zuwanderer zum kreis und
einfach sie sind dass sie vor allem
[Musik]
wieso bin ich schnell
bei lancia mit hawaii bilder wir server
und tourismus francis nyt am hut er
schaffte am ort wo hawaii immer ganz
andere zahler hang welt wie die
bekanntheit breitet der französisch
monteur auf der militärbasis von pearl
harbor
gleich nach der highschool ging ich zu
haben
ich hatte keine klaren beruflichen
vorstellungen
die armee ist ein guter start und vor
allem bieten sie stipendien fürs college
man bekommt lebenserfahrung und lernt
verschiedene länder kennen reise und
länder entdecken das hat für die
franziskaner in re aktie
als ich im militär war wurde ich 2009
2010 nach afghanistan geschickt
es war eine sehr beängstigende zurück
ich wusste nicht ob ich überleben würde
aber es machte mich auch zu einem
besseren menschen
ich wurde stärker und bekamen an mich zu
glauben dass und auch darauf zu
vertrauen dass es einen nächsten tag
geben wird
[Musik]
aber habe ich eine stabile arbeit
ich könnte mich und familienaufgaben und
später auch für eine familie
[Musik]
jungwirth welt entdecken ist für fabian
viel unbelastet fußballs dabei entsprach
aufenthalt gemacht sie sperrt normal auf
dienstag fähre hat sich francis
kennengelernt
[Musik]
honolulu gleiche spruch schule wo aus
sie besucht hat
dafür bringen uns am schlusstag sind zum
heiko ein richtiger gemacht
nicht so im internet einfach auf dank
der schneller vor ort mit dem francis
hat fabian noch gut 8 minute eine
arbeitsbewilligung überhaupt
auf green kreuth aber als unbeschränkte
offen teils recht hat sie über zwei
jahre gewartet und hätte wie er im film
matrix beamte müsse vorstellig werden
und ist nicht wirklich freundlich
gesehen und hat dann irgendwann
irgendwie 46 haben zum beispiel mir
verhört und ich bin der kugel
wir bieten keine gewähr irgendwelche
kollegen fragen und fragt schließlich
mit der vpn deiner produkt glaubt dass
sie weckten die usa wie bliebe
[Musik]
wir haben keine ahnung was hinter
unseren rücken geredet wird
einmal sagte eine dame sie ist sehr jung
erinnerst du dich es ist eher selten
dass diesbezüglich jemand etwas
schlechtes sagt der altersunterschied
belastet uns nicht nur dass ich auf
deine gesundheit achten
der kleine familie von der evelyn und
technik
[Musik]
haben diese schon etiketten
nein ich glaube nicht eveline suter
leipzig jahre in der stadt
die schauspielerin und sängerin böse der
schweiz ich sie vor allem durch ihre
musical hauptrollen bekannt wurde
[Musik]
evelyn in osttirol ist mitte vierzig
show familie gewünscht
und der gilt es jetzt beschützer einer
pandemie ist labels new york härter
wurde und evelyn fühlt sich nummer
sicher
[Musik]
sie besichtigen kann so paradis ka nicht
bedroht wurde mit dem die frage ob es
wirklich losgeht dieser behauptet
geschlossen
es ist doch sehr anders schalten und das
kommen damit du hast wirklich wollte
nicht hier oder und irgendwo mehr
gesehen ich weiß das ist ein schöner
machen hoffentlich können wir uns
erholen
new york und co sieht das hat uns
zugesetzt werde von einer weltmetropole
in der schweiz die stadt dennoch
ziemlich große schritt vor allem für der
evelyn ihrem mann danny der
hollywood-produzent aber das glas
ich bin es gewohnt an einen neuen ort
anzukommen und loszulegen
schauen wir was die schweiz zu bieten
hat
als mission impossible mitproduziert
er ist ein richtiger new york ich bin
hier aufgewachsen
das ist der park meiner kindheit erste
mal trafen sich die beiden immer casting
in der schweiz es war im warteraum eines
hotels in zürich
ich musste sie unentwegt anschauen
sie war so atemberaubend schön
sie hatte ein bezauberndes lächeln
diesen moment werde ich nie vergessen
er spricht wie behauptet für die orte
ziehen ihre beziehung im zweiten anlauf
braucht s baujahr stolz hält sich ihre
weg zum york nummer kriegst du erst mal
wieder gesehen ist es wichtig so ist man
bisher auch keinen bonus stellen dann
hätte mich okay ich hatte gerade eine
lange in ihre hinter mir ich habe zwei
kinder
die trennung musste ich zuerst
verarbeiten
und da kommt diese liebe in mein leben
ich war vorsichtig
ich wollte nichts überstürzen und doch
eigentlich wollen wir ab dem moment
unzertrennlich
[Musik]
es ist jetzt nicht so dass ich voll auf
das taxi war und ich bin am anfang auch
rechts kritisch gesehen so denkt ja sich
ja doch ganz andere kulturen ich bin
noch nicht so lange in afrika will ich
denn das sei wirklich und da bin ich am
anfang eher zu kalt im gegensatz zu
marcel proaktives oder davon überzeugen
ihre kultur sind komplett
unterschiedlich aber das ziel ist klar
miriam und chris wenn die rote gefällt
es dir ich liebe es
mailand ist einfach nur flach hier ist
das glas immer grün
und das ist nicht staubig
das ist ein großer unterschied ist zum
ersten mal bei dieser wird für
gemeinnützige organisation sambia jetzt
in den ferien der schweiz wohne zweite
miriam ihre ältere im thurgau
sie sind ihre hochzeit am vorbereiten
[Musik]
heutzutage ist das wieder moderne etwas
selber zu machen aber nicht in sambia
wieso soll ich meine einladungskarten
selber machen würden sie dort sagen ich
bin manchmal perfektionist ich bin so
aufgewachsen mein vater musste alles
seine ordnung haben
das hat mich beeinflusst
majdic und danach nie mehr informationen
für die luft aus der schweiz ihre
dienste thiendorf was laid sondern in
der hauptstadt lusaka in afrika ist oft
so wenn wenn hochzeit ist und einfach
jeder richter verhört oder ist und man
jetzt eigentlich zur riesenfest
veranstalten wir uns eigentlich auch
private halter
da ich im kukksi warum es nicht dies
macht aber auch wenn lied vor der
schweiz mit sowie drei jahren lebe wenn
die beide vorderhand sambia trotzdem
soll der krise und bezug zur schweiz
überholt
ich mag es dass es hier so ruhig ist in
einem land sind die leute auf der straße
sie tanzen und singen aber ich liebe es
hier
es ist schön hier so ruhig für zukunft
dar
wer weiß nicht ob mir für immer werden
das ist unser haus von hinten mit den
solarpanels
so viele solarpanels auch hier ist es
einfach schön
es gefällt dir ja so macht muss doch und
so ist es doch okay es geht auch noch
ein anderer weg und am anfang stand das
album noch nicht ohne bemerkte also
sicher nicht nur würde mich jetzt immer
so gemacht oder auch so machen für die
tournee ist wichtig und es geht ja immer
so eine schöne aussicht oder eher witzig
wo man vielleicht vorher nicht wenn wir
im land und ist im garten klappte
[Musik]
trotzdem über kurz oder lang simona
wieder zurückgespielt
wie hübsch marielle angezogen hat
[Musik]
fürs glück buch daran sind die familien
um sich und zehn jahren für zehn euro
könnte jetzt ein richtiges auf er weiß
dass die monat mit so einer rallye gar
nicht ran anfang etwas probe fertig ist
verboten
[Musik]
in unserer beziehung geht es oft um
kompromisse würde ich das auto kaufen
könnte sie im gegenzug wieder sehr viel
von mir verlangen
da
[Musik]
es ist natürlich schön mannes und das
romantisch vorstellen der letzte mini
und der familie und das problem die
kinder sehen
ich habe mir die filme wie dem mini
platzieren
[Musik]
anderes ist jetzt wichtiger als einen
mini zu kaufen
ja wir müssen zuerst entscheide treffen
schauen was die nähere zukunft bringt ob
ihr in italien bleiben oder nicht
garage der familie ausflug was mich
beeindruckt
sie macht kein bogen um die schwierige
thema binationale und das bazl werde die
post hat der umzug nach italien eure
beziehung verändert
andrea problem stellt und vielleicht
will muster komfortzone ist schwierig es
kreierte problem und muss die zusammen
damit ist aber die gleiche sieht weiß
eben noch keiner geschafft
ja das ist so man muss nicht aufeinander
verlassen können
man hat sonst niemanden welche job
möglichkeiten gäbe es für dich in der
schweiz die schweiz hat zwar keine
klassische autoindustrie
aber die schweiz oder eine große
maschinenindustrie dort gibt es
möglichkeiten die pens aber ihr würdet
nur in die schweiz ziehen wenn du dort
einen job hat ist der kompromiss ist
dass wir in die schweiz nicht an einen
neuen ort gehen aber wir gehen nur in
die schweiz wenn sich eine gute
möglichkeit auftut
[Musik]
meine berufliche zukunft
obwohl ich mir jetzt ich kann mir sehr
gut vorstellen aber periode da in
italien bieber bringt ihn noch nie ich
finde es ist wichtig dass mir wenn mir
vor der schule liegt das ist wirklich
bewusst weil wenn man das ist nicht
wirklich schlau anstellt und und im
moment
es bleibt spannend
[Musik]
mehr
die kerle
[Musik]
wenn ihr die emotionen zeigt aber wird
einmal darum habe ich dann einfach es
ist immer ehrlich und gibt mir die
sicherheit wurde eigentlich ist ja das
ist immer der bahn
[Musik]
ein überraschungsbesuch zum sechzigsten
geburtstag vor ihrer moral kreis oder
unglauben land gemacht und monat lang
ihre liebste und ihre alte heimat noch
mal so richtig genießen bevor sie den
zug gott auf san francisco yeste plank
sie aber jetzt geschichte
dramatische wende knorke sagt mona
dafür danke
aber was ist in europa sehr neu am
mittwoch hatte der bursch raum mit einer
absage also dass das visum abgelehnt hat
und dann bin ich natürlich also völlig
die visums verlängerung ist altländer
einfach soja und grund ist die farben
und das management das was er misst wie
somit also dafür setzt das nein das
haben wir aus abgeflogen
das problem neue und sind nur für orte
wie das viele andere machen für sichere
aufenthaltsbewilligung dass heinz
bewusst nicht wähle bist viel druck der
bbc
darum ist sie erst of san francisco wo
sie stellen aus kindergärten gesamt
visum kay overbeck das kaiser mit höhen
und tiefen
[Musik]
was braucht es eigentlich dass so eine
beziehung über zwei länder hinweg ja am
18 ja nervenärzte hughes billiger machen
ich habe die letzte präfektur krieg und
das ist ihm so ich schnitte und dann hat
er mit mir schluss gemacht und ich weiß
noch dass facebook und daniel flug
gebracht
ich brauche es jetzt ich brauch das für
mich okay aber er muss wie das sagen
dass ich weitermachen mit mir und er ist
ein crew und ich fand im körper der
hotelzimmertür und ich und er mitten im
koffer mit der bmk erstellt es setzt
sich aufs bett zeit also was über was
reden und im moment bin ich sogar
trainer aufgelöst und gesagt nur warum
vergisst du mich einfach nicht warum
macht schnell wieder mit dem nennwert
und dann hat sich das ist und ich weiß
was mit hand und fuß
sie stärke die zweiten anlauf hätte
match aufnahmeprüfung fürs informatik
studium bestanden
[Musik]
die heimatliebe flöhen thalersee trifft
sich die ganze familie york beschäftigen
auch ihren vater damit dem wie es um das
in der luft hat und man weiß nie kommt
sie wieder zurückkommen noch als beste
tv special ist das wort 0 in san
francisco einmal auf um ist schweizer
hockey und keine form die rezept für
ihren vater krank wie drüben aber und
irgendwann geld und glück castelen
zunehmend wieder zurück darunter
kalifornien
das weiß ich nicht aber dessen zimmer
wir kommen und die familie
noel hat sich so gefreut auf die wochen
wie ihre familie des spiels aber jetzt
liegt über allem entscheiden wenn und
ybbsitz rock of san francisco kann ist
völlig ungewiss
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
du schaust hat ich weiß das ist ein
liebling ich werde gerade ein bisschen
traurig ich möchte zu dir nach hause
kommen
agnes merkt wenn ich meine
naja er spürt dass du traurig bist
[Musik]
ja
ich habe angst dass ich alles verliere
du kannst uns liefern
[Musik]
buchs new york im himmel sehen uns wir
danken dir für unser wunderbares kind
hast du meinen pass gib mir einen kuss
über chd berlins new york bleibt aber
sie so dass immer wenn irgendwo [ __ ]
berufen
aber es ist immer dasselbe wurzeln
schlagen wieder rausziehen
die wurzeln rausziehen das ist immer
schmerzfrei aber sie können dann wieder
wachsen
[Musik]
david moore
tschüss pass auf dich auf
[Musik]
evelyn und apple
dort trifft es ist als wäre ich auf
einem anderen planeten
neues visum
[Musik]
ich habe für das amerikanische sie haben
dann villa bewies dass sie die letzten
drei jahre und so wieder zurück die
zukünftige schwiegermutter gibt der
schweiz ihre tipps für das erfolgs leben
eine frau muss wie eine biber sein
[Musik]
die kerle
präsentiert wurde von dr